in september of 2019 there were rumors
of a paper where google claimed that it
had achieved quantum supremacy
in october of that year google released
the paper stating that it had achieved
quantum supremacy with its quantum
computer which had run calculations for
a task in 200 seconds and that the same
task would take the most powerful
supercomputers at least 10
000 years to solve ibm the new york
multinational technology giant refuted
these claims almost immediately claiming
that they could solve the problem with
their super computer
in just two and a half days now you've
gotta wonder
why is this statement from google so
important that ibm seems to not want it
to be true
what is quantum supremacy and what is
quantum computing
also why is the chinese government
heavily investing hundreds of millions
into the same project welcome back to
our channel
if you haven't already make sure you hit
the subscribe button and ring that bell
so you're notified every time we upload
a new video alright so it may sound
weird to talk about google beating
innovation in a surprise manner
i mean we should expect these kinds of
landmark achievements from them every
once in a while right
they did after all create the most
efficient information tool with their
search engine that
generates hundreds of millions of
answers to your questions in half a
second
and although you'll only visit the
second page when working on a school
project
google search engine is so good that it
will search you
as well they also created the google
recorder app in 2019 that makes
transcribing
recording editing and even translation
seem like child's play as the app was
voted the best app
and the recorder app is so good that
some people even claim that it doesn't
stop working
even when you shut it off but no quantum
supremacy is eons beyond these
innovations in terms of possible impacts
so this brings us back to what is
quantum supremacy and quite simply it is
when a task is run on and solved quickly
by a quantum computer
a task that is so hard a classic
computer would not be able to solve it
in this case google made use of its own
quantum computer built from scratch
sycamore to achieve quantum supremacy
sycamore is part of the company's quest
to develop a useful
error-corrected computer by the end of
the decade and to help meet this goal
google has built a quantum ai campus in
santa barbara
with hardware research labs a data
center and facilities for developing
quantum processor chips
by the end of the decade google would
have spent billions to perfect
quantum computing but what really is
quantum computing
to understand quantum computing we'll
need to make use of some simple concepts
from quantum mechanics
and to do that we'll need to start at
the very beginning
for over a century physicists have tried
to understand the physical properties of
objects at the subatomic level
also known as quantum mechanics some of
the greatest minds like einstein
heisenberg and niels bohr have tried
their hands at it
because quantum mechanics was hard to
understand and seemingly irrational
erwin schrodlinger kind of made a
popular quantum mechanics for dummies
thought experiment that is now known as
schrodlinger's cat
we might consider schrodinger's cat this
experiment consisted of a closed steel
container
a cat and a radioactive poison that will
detonate randomly
now because we do not know whether the
poison has detonated we can think of the
cat as being both alive and dead until
we actually open the box to observe it
this attribute of being in two different
states at once until measured is called
superposition
and it's a characteristic feature of
subatomic particles like electrons and
photons
now while classic computers mimic humans
in the way that we carry out
calculations using bits of ones and
zeros as data
quantum computers like sycamore mimic
nature using quantum bits or qubits of
both 1 and 0 as data these qubits can
exist in both states of data at once and
change accordingly to give the required
answer for a task
and this also means that compared to
bits qubits process a ridiculous amount
of information
faster and this ability to process more
information faster
increases as you increase both the bits
of a classical computer
and qubits of a quantum computer like
google sycamore
for instance unlike two classical bits
that will exist in either of the four
states
two qubits can exist in all four states
at once
three qubits in eight states four and
sixteen
and so on the qubits in the circuit are
entangled in such a way that this helps
the computer affect the changes across
all the qubits to arrive at the correct
state
that generates the solution to your task
this behavior is also derived from
quantum mechanics and was described by
einstein as
shbukhoft femverkin or spooky action at
a distance
this is the effect where two particles
are correlated with each other in such a
way that you can actually predict the
properties and behavior of any one of
the particles just using one of them
no matter how far apart they are from
each other google's current quantum
computers have less than 100 cubits and
a quantum computer with 300 qubits would
have more states than we currently have
atoms in the observable universe
however the company has set a goal of
creating a computer with a million
qubits that's a goal that requires a lot
of patience and hard work which the
brilliant team at google and quantum ai
are ready to undertake the reason why
building quantum computers has been an
issue is because qubits are not stable
and need
special conditions to work google's
quantum computers like this steampunk
like chandelier
has something called the josephson
junction that converts the bits to
qubits
meanwhile the build of the computer
ensures that the electrical and magnetic
interference are avoided while
superconducting is also achieved by
using the cryostat to bring the
temperature close to absolute zero
all this delicate care is necessary
because the possible monetary gains
as well as social advancements are quite
simply immense
and maybe even unknown so we've
understood some concepts of quantum
mechanics and quantum computing
or maybe we haven't maybe it's both but
you can't really explain it but you kind
of get it
well i hate to break it to you but your
brain has just been superimposed
and it has massive implications if fully
implemented i mean we'll be solving
problems with the power of nature and
the universe
and because quantum mechanics is
actually not fully understood by anybody
including scientists these quantum
computers can help us have a better
understanding of quantum mechanics
itself as more progress is made
google's quantum computers will have
real world applications for instance
it would be able to correctly predict
the best combination of molecules for
drugs
which is today done by scientists in a
sort of trial and error method
this would save a lot of time as well as
cut off a whole lot of cost and waste
and speaking of predictions it can also
be useful in creating models for
projects and theories as well as making
financial forecasts
they can also be used in the
implementation of even safer encryption
technology than any we currently have
quantum computers would make
cryptographic functions for blockchains
look like a joke
but on the flip side they can easily
hack private keys as well as other
security systems using weaker technology
so i guess we know why the chinese
government wants to get there first
however the presence of a quantum
computer does not mean that classical
computers will cease to exist
since they're fundamentally different
with respect to the computational
processes that they mimic
quantum computers are just here to solve
the really data-heavy tasks that would
otherwise be impossible even on the most
powerful supercomputers that we have
today
not to help you open two chrome tabs at
once so ibm and google could have
disagreements about this wonderful
technology but the crazy possibilities
of this technology mean one thing
and one thing alone when everyone is
done perfecting the tech
apple is probably going to do this
awesome press reveal about some new
innovation to its customers
and call it something aptly you know
icubit
or mac iq what name do you think they'd
give the product if they made their own
super computer
also who do you think will be the
fastest to perfect super computers
google ibm or the chinese government
let us know in the comments below and if
you enjoyed this video make sure to give
it a like
and check out more awesome ones on the
simply tech channel thanks for watching
and we'll see you next time